tyler alexander is going to tow the
rubber tonight
for his 28th appearance in his first
start of the season
that's a good way to start his afternoon
though he gets kiner falefa
staring at strike three one away here's
eli white on the ground to jammer
candelario jack talked about him earlier
in the broadcast
and on cue number two this is adolesce
garcia
and this one up the middle backhand stop
little acrobatics out there and then the
throw
sails over first and so garcia is on
that'll be a base hit that's a tough
play
for castro going up the middle short
comes over right you worry about these
guys banging into each other right here
almost getting kicked in the face
that had to be a little bit of a
distraction joey gallo at the plate you
have to be careful this is a lefty who
hits
lefties 3-2 again swinging a miss he got
him with a change-up down in the strike
zone
what a pitch that's a big league pitch
folks terrific
job for alexander mike fulton evans
making that start this afternoon for the
rangers this will be number 20 for him
two and nine record
5.91 era and for the first time in his
career in the regular seasons making a
start on short rest
away here in the bottom half of the
first inning and that brings up
jonathan scope right back up the middle
off the mound nick solaf can't handle it
and jonathan scope is aboard to that
aboard for eric haas
drives one deep left field that was gone
from the time he connected oh baby
big time blast three run shot
i'll tell you what this kid has really
put a spark into this ball team and he
sits on a hanger
and he rips it to the left field three
runs now for tyler alexander to work
with
hugs all over in the dugout smiles
everywhere candelario now the hitter
here is swinging a miss by candelario
he goes down on a slider first strikeout
for fulton emmitt here's a check swing
on a pitch down and in did he go
and third base umpire chad fairchild
says yes castro goes around on that
slider so a pair of
strikeouts back to back here but it
comes after the three run blast by haas
three-nothing tigers as we head to the
bottom of the second will he castro zach
short
and victor reyes against mike fulton and
willie castro
sends one to deep right center field
that's going to be up the alley
all the way just prior to the wall
castro wants three
he's on his way the throw is not in time
ahead first triple for willie castro
welcome back
always exciting to see a guy in his
first at-bat
make a contribution that's what they all
want to do willie castro gets a pitch
over the middle of the plate we call him
cookies he didn't miss his cookie
and we've got one down here in the
second with victor reyes coming up
fly ball right field that one's deep
going back
is dull to make the catch on the track
castro will tag and score
tigers lead four nothing two men are out
but another run is in it's four
nothing two two this one lifted out to
left
long run out there for eli why did he
makes a diving catch
what a play by eli white airborne when
he caught that one he
landed right on the line a terrific way
to wrap up this bottom half of the
second inning
jonathan scope robbie grossman and eric
haas for the tigers here in the bottom
of the third
a rip to left into the corner for
jonathan scope
he wants two he will dig for two and he
will cruise into second base with a
stand-up double
to start the third scope doubled
grossman walked
ha standing in with another rbi
opportunity
a strikeout of hoss an eighth pitch at
bat
but fulty stuck with it he gets his
first out of the inning
so they're two outs here in the bottom
of the third inning men at the corners
and harold castro coming up first pitch
to castro dribble to second
solax there he sidearms to first and
that ends the inning as
fultonevich wiggles out of the jam so
joey reaches the rangers have a one out
base runner here in the top of the
fourth inning and jonah heim the
battered
hits this one off the end of the bat
over third and that one is
in play takes a weird hop off that
angled fence
gallow into third and then he slams on
the brakes so the heim double
has the rangers set up now in this
fourth inning runners at second and
third one out and andy banya is coming
up
alexander's one two and that one
lofted into short right field that'll be
trouble it drops in base hit
gallows in heim stopped at third took
a wide turn but held up the rangers on
the board with an rbi single from andy
bonnez here in the top of the fourth
as they now trail four to one alexander
will be allowed to go back to work here
against david dahl
he gets doll looking that was a real
fine pitch
bottom of the zone dow to me like he was
sitting on a breaking ball
that will indeed be the end of the day
for tyler alexander
culberson coming up solid start for
tyler alexander and gives way
to erasmus ramirez swing and a miss he
got him with the cutter
charlie culverson strikes out nice job
by ramirez to strain two
went out nobody on in the bottom of the
fourth inning so here's zach short
zach short fly ball left field deep
white going back looking up
and gone zach short
number five second in as many days
five one tigers in the fourth there you
go makes a great pitch against castro
and then hangs one
and short puts a big buggy whip on it to
take advantage of that bad pitch
as they extend their lead to 5-1 so
here's victor reyes
victor reyes throws one to right the
power
surge continues reyes with his second
bomb of the season 6-1
tigers victor reaches down and
uses his hands and upper arm strength to
pull that one
three homers for the tigers on the day
already
and the rangers trying to build
something here in the sixth minute first
and second with one out
for david dahl dahl an easy swing and a
little flare out into right center it
drops for the base hit
rounding third is joey gallo he comes in
to score
dahl with a nice smooth easy swing
delivers an rbi single and the rangers
now trail six to two for dahl
his 16th run betted in this season solac
walks
turns the lineup over and the bases are
loaded so
is he representing a potential tying run
here the 2-1
and he does that one out to left field
it gets down base hit
ibanez is in dahl being waived he'll
score
a two-run single by kiner falefa and
he's made it a two-run game
it produced two a single for kiner
falefa to get the rangers back to within
a pair
at six four victor reyes moves to third
grossman with two walks and a flyout
here today here's the one two
the other way and that's good there's an
rbi single for robbie grossman
he plays victor reyes and the tigers
lead is back to three
seven to four robbie grossman's 300th
career rbi
might not seem like a lot but that is
such a crucial run
the banya is two for three today with a
couple of pop-up singles
to the moment not quite enough this ball
well struck deep out to center field
long run out there for badou and he
can't get to it that's in triples alley
and ibanez will easily have a triple to
start this eighth inning so here's david
dahl
struck out to center field that'll be
deep enough to get the run home so dahl
with a sac fly ibanez tags
and score and it's back to a two-run
game gregory soto takes over on the
mound
he will face eli white adolesce garcia
and joey gallo and the leadoff man is
aboard
for texas in the ninth here's adolesce
garcia there's the first out of the
inning
nasty slider down and away back door and
now
power against power soto against
gallo he sits him down
two outs in the ninth that leaves it up
to jonah heim
on the ground to short like yesterday
you bet
a seven game winning streak for the
tigers nine straight at home
and an eighth sweep this
season